You see there's somebody who wants to meet you
you don't know him no but you took
his name and now he wants it back
no sorry i still don't get it it is western
sydney home to the newest edition of the marvel
movie franchise the seven news chopper captured
these scenes today as work resume building the
set for the upcoming production shang chi and
the legend of the ten rings it's understood
that all cast and crew have now arrived from
overseas and after completing their required
quarantine shooting will begin in the coming
days 18 weeks later than originally planned
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this is going
to be my new marvel shang chi movie video they're
still filming the movie right now in san francisco
we have a couple clips to break down so if you're
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos a little while ago they also
shuffled the order of the marvel phase 4 movies
so i'll explain that during the video too but just
starting with the big stuff first if you didn't
see recently they've actually been filming in san
francisco why is that a big deal because there is
a lot of big stuff that happened in san francisco
in the mcu so far probably the biggest is that
san francisco is where the ant-man movies take
place both ant-man and ant-man and the wasp it's
also where the venom movie took place i'll explain
why that's relevant in a second is where carnage
is being held in san quentin prison here so it's
where that post-credit scene took place and where
part of venom 2 is going to take place that's also
the exact same prison where scott lang was being
held at the beginning of the first ant-man movie
when he first got out and it's also supposedly
the prison that's featured here where the vulture
is when morbius runs into him and he has that
what's up doc moment during the morbius trailer
along with carnage in scorpion because scorpion is
supposed to be in the same prison as the vulture
whole lot of sinister sick stuff going on there
in the morbius movie on the sony side of things i
know everyone's wondering how they're going to try
and integrate that stuff with the mcu spider-man 3
stuff that they're filming right now so see it all
is kind of connected remember the core operating
phrase way back in the day everything is connected
it'll all make sense real soon but san francisco
was also featured recently in avengers end game as
part of the ant-man scenes just a little while ago
remember even though it's 2023 in the mcu they'll
kind of explain the timeline at the beginning of
the new marvel phase 4 movies some of them take
place in the past some of them will take place
in the present scott lang's van was actually
being held in san francisco in this warehouse
everyone pour one out for that rat that
saved the universe that rat is the real hero
saving scott lang and helping him get out of the
quantum realm there's also the matter of sonny
birch in the quote-unquote mysterious villain
that he works for with billions of dollars to
burn on hank pym's quantum technology that's all
happening in and around san francisco as well the
prison that trevor is being held in during that
all hail the king one shot that marvel did after
iron man 3 when the real mandarin's forces come
to take him away when he's being interviewed there
just totally doesn't get what's going on wait a
minute that's actually happening in seagate prison
which is actually in georgia on the east coast so
remember all this is happening in san francisco
on the west coast mostly because a lot of the
events of the shang chi movie the backstory the
mandarin character the real 10 rings take place
in and around china or the south pacific somewhere
in this region the reason why so much of this
movie seems like it takes place in and around san
francisco though in the united states is probably
just because shang qi might be living in san
francisco at the beginning of the movie that might
just be his hometown before the mandarin and the
tournament of the ten rings the way that scott
lang lives there when he's not doing avengers
stuff it's just that all the scenes that they're
filming for shane chi take place in and around
the chinatown neighborhood of san francisco
if any of you have been there in real life
ant-man and venom for instance over in the venom
universe just live in a different part of the town
it's the exact same phenomenon for the new
york city area in the marvel cinematic universe
a ton of big marvel characters live in and around
new york city spider-man lives in queens over here
captain america is from brooklyn just below the
avengers tower was in midtown the sanctum and dr
strange are in greenwich village in the new
kamala khan miss marvel character that they
just announced a couple weeks ago she lives
in jersey city the new avengers base was in
upstate new york too but that's sort of a hole
in the ground right now after avengers end game
thanos obliterated it so they're probably
not going to be rebuilding that right away
mostly because we have nick fury's secret sword
space station from the comics bringing back
around to the fake mandarin in the real mandarin
i know a lot of you are hoping for some sort of
cameo from trevor in the shang chi movie justin
hammer also chilling there too remarking on how
he's just sitting around and nothing is going
on sam rockwell did say that he would love to
come back i feel like justin hammer as a character
is usually most for comedic relief but you could
also put him on a thunderbolts team eventually
the thing about seagate prison is that actually
by the time we got to captain america civil war
thunderbolt ross had started locking up the most
powerful marvel villains the most dangerous people
in the raft so if there's a villain that's still
alive out there that you haven't seen die in the
mcu movies they're in the raft right now that's
basically what kevin feige says like the leader
from the incredible hulk movie the abomination
they're all chilling out in the raft right now
all the thunderbolt stuff they're going to cover
in the falcon and winter soldier episodes
they're almost done filming that so don't worry
that's all happening alongside the movies
all that stuff will cross over and weave in
probably not a whole lot with the shang chi movie
though all the footage that they're filming here
of this giant chase scene with the bus around
the san francisco chinatown area is probably
just the mandarin's forces trying to hunt down
shang chi at some point during the movie we
don't really know if this is happening early
in the movie or towards the end of the movie
they did the exact same thing during ant-man and
the wasp where you have a couple of different
big action scenes in and around the san francisco
streets but the other big shang chi clip here is
of the traditional asian village it has no signs
of modern technology it might have something to do
with flashback scenes or explaining the origin of
the real mandarin to the mcu and his rise to power
in his quest to acquire the ten rings of power
forming the ten rings organization part of the
movie is supposed to be him trying to actually
get the physical 10 rings of power implying that
he doesn't actually have all them when the movie
starts this is really where we start to get into
the iron man easter eggs of the mcu people always
wonder how they're going to weave in tony stark's
legacy to the future marvel movies if you actually
went to the marvel studios panel at comic con the
year before they did the comic-con panel for the
first iron man movie you would have heard kevin
feige talking about how they were planning on
making the iron man movie and how the mandarin
was going to be the main villain they never fully
explained why they swerved on the mandarin during
pre-production but at some point when they were
still developing the movie they decided to change
the main villain to obadiah stain and then the
mandarin sort of became this easter egg that
they tried to include an iron man 3 in a really
roundabout way pissed off the fans that's why
they made the one shot all hail the king to let
you know no there is a real mandarin out there
but the whole thing with the 10 rings of power is
that they were actually created by an alien race
so we've already had so many space-based movies
in the marvel cinematic universe for at least
the shane chief franchise whatever that trilogy
winds up being because they do intend to make a
trilogy if everything goes well as they'll sort of
serve as like the new infinity stones at least on
a smaller scale they're not nearly as powerful as
the infinity stones for the most part they're just
describing the shang chi movie as sort of marvel's
version of bruce lee's enter the dragon everybody
has seen at least clips of enter the dragon if
you haven't actually seen the movie please go
watch it because it is amazing it's a classic
the actual shanxi character was created in the
comics in 1973 during this big kung fu craze
that was going on in the 1970s in pop culture
bruce lee was blowing up at the time so they
basically created him to be marvel's bruce lee
even the actor who plays shang chi is describing
his character as marvel's version of bruce lee
but just like during enter the dragon shang chi
gets invited to this special tournament tournament
of the 10 rings that the mandarin organizes just
like the villain of enter the dragon but the whole
plan for the shang chi character is that he will
eventually cross paths with people like nick fury
once they land on his radar that will also kick
them into the running for future avengers movies
when nick fury is running around assembling a
new avengers team speaking of other easter eggs
too i know people are wondering about thing fang
fume and we talk about the enter the dragon movie
that's more of a metaphor for the bruce lee movie
because bruce lee is quote-unquote the dragon
but there's been a lot of talk about them actually
including the fing fang foon character the real
dragon of the marvel comics inside the shang
chi movie in some form like we'll actually see
a dragon in a marvel movie the big thing that
they just changed though with the marvel face 4
movie schedule is that now shang chi is coming out
before the eternals movie originally was coming
out after the eternals movie and eternals was
meant to sort of set up the idea of x-men along
with Wandavision in the mcu shang chi himself
didn't interact with the x-men a ton in the
comics so i'm not really expecting a ton of those
easter eggs in the shang chi movie but it's always
possible i think most of the mutant stuff that
we'll see will be in Wandavision than the eternals
movie then slowly will build up to the full-blown
marvel rebooted x-men movie in the mcu but that's
not going to happen until way down in marvel
phase 5. if you have any big questions about
what's going on with shang chi or the other marvel
phase 4 movies just let me know in the comments
below but as we get new previews i'll just do
more videos about it everyone click here to learn
about what's going on with spider-man 3 in doctor
strange 2 crossover and click here for my venom 2
trailer video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!